for them but you know it's a win for me
my birthday
[Applause]
with some fabulous Grand Queens come on
out y'all
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
so how about some bubbling how about
some bubbly from my brand new line of
Whoopi Prosecco I love hosting
Gatherings with friends and family
that's why I created movie Prosecco you
can have a great time anywhere you are
with friends and holidays are coming out
it's a white sparkling mind wine made
with organic grapes it's harvested in
the Benito region of Italy but you know
what you are you getting the boss and
take off
well you're getting a coupon I'm sorry
you're getting a coupon we'll be right
back
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's December 20th 2022 and we just
bludgeoned you over the head in the
middle of that clip as we played it for
you Phoenix apologized to me
and now I apologize to you as the
audience that we started you cold open
with the view
drag queens
masks masks the most jarring part of
that drag queens are everywhere right
now literally you hire a plumber someone
shows up to your house if it's not a
dude dressed as a chickie going what's
going on here everybody's a drag queen
now but the masks that those bananas
wackadoodle people in the audience of
the view have nothing better to do than
waste three hours in the middle of the
day to go to that taping
put on masks to be there to then watch a
bunch of men dressed as clownish women
celebrate Woofy Goldberg and her
Prosecco
Lord give me the strength
we have a tremendous show for you guys
today uh I would apologize I'd like to
apologize up top we did not have a live
stream yesterday I was up in Orlando
it's about a four hour drive from here
in Miami we drove up to Orlando I did an
event with Governor DeSantis it was the
freedom blueprint event that he put
together which in essence was a giant
group of uh parents who are running for
different school boards superintendent
different positions who want to take
back the schools now we're doing a
pretty nice job of it here in Florida
and the schools are relatively sane and
as you guys know DeSantis has gotten a
lot of the woke stuff out of the schools
but they are not stopping I mean that's
that's the beauty of this guy he keeps
pushing they want to make sure that
every school is safe that every kid is
safe etc etc uh so there were a few
speakers some people running for
different positions the governor spoke
and then I spoke so here's just a small
clip of the governor then we'll throw to
a clip of me and then we'll get to the
show school systems are important but
they do not supersede the rights of
parents to raise their own children you
know I did this debate in the governor's
race and we did it in this Auditorium
and there was like 100 some people 200
people and basically my opponent wheeled
in people from Broward teachers union
okay they all had the same shirt on
whatever and so what was said was okay
you guys are here but it's not about the
crowd don't interrupt don't Hoot and
Holler don't do any of that or whatever
so what do they do they scream the whole
time anytime I would talk they'd try to
drown drown me out and all this stuff
and whatever I mean I can handle it I
just didn't did whatever but I'm just
thinking to myself these are people that
are in our school system and that's the
way they're conducting themselves
so the governor spoke for about 45
minutes I think we're going to post some
other clips of it at that moment in
particular I wanted to show to you guys
because I referenced it a couple weeks
ago as you may remember I was at the
debate between the governor and Charlie
Chris the name that I promise you I'll
never say on this show again it's just
uh the guy's completely irrelevant but
he makes an interesting point there
because I had told you guys after the
debate what was so interesting because
on when you watch things on television
you don't get the full picture of what's
Happening actually in the room itself
and and there were split it was about
200 people total about 100 uh Chris
supporters about 100 DeSantis supporters
and all the DeSantis supporters were
individual people and everybody was kind
of dressed nice like they were out for
an evening and they seemed professional
as if they had jobs and then as the
Santa said they bust in these Broward
teachers people they were all wearing
the exact same shirt uh there's there is
reason to believe that they might have
even been paid to be there but the point
is that he really made uh was that they
did not follow any of the rules meaning
that they were screaming and hollering a
few of them had to be be kicked out they
were booing and jeering and the DeSantis
side simply did not do that and I think
that gets to a sort of bigger point
about Society right now which is that
some people have some rules right those
rules may not always be totally right
and and the people may not totally
always abide by them but but if you're
watching this I mean some of the things
we talk about like we believe in the
rule of law right like we believe in the
Constitution the Bill of Rights we
believe in God given rights things of
that nature right doesn't mean you're
always perfectly applying them but we
have some set of rules and then when you
go to events and they tell you what the
rules are you try to abide by those
rules there's a we have like a social
contract that says hey this is how we're
going to behave in in public spaces the
other side doesn't do that I think
that's one of the things that we're
really going to have to negotiate going
forward like what do you do as you try
to build something and one side is just
there to burn it down what do you do
about that and anyway here's a couple
highlights from uh from my talk and then
we will get to the meat of the show and
if you noticed although he had a couple
notes on the podium here he basically
was looking at you guys the entire time
45 minutes looking straight at you which
is in stark contrast to the president of
the United States
who needs a teleprompter to tell you
what his wife's name is so the media the
mainstream Media or the corporate press
whatever phrase you want to use the fake
news whatever it might be they're not
your friends they are not your friends
and they will never be your friends
right they will never give the governor
a fair shake they will never give
Florida a fair Shake because Freedom the
idea that the individual which is the
root of Western Civilization that you
and your children and your spouses that
there is something unique about you and
valuable about you that is the hardest
thing for them to control you're here
because they finally pushed too far
right they just pushed too far look what
happened in Virginia which caused Glenn
youngin to win look what yeah look what
happened right here in Florida I mean 20
points 20 points
as Florida becomes
the the Pinnacle of freedom in the
United States I mean do you guys really
realize that I can truly tell you that
as a as a new Floridian that we live in
the freest place in the world do you
understand that
we really do guys the United States has
all sorts of problems right now but we
are the freest country in the world and
we live in without question the free
estate in the world so when you guys get
involved when you guys get involved you
are defending that freedom
all right so we're going to put the full
thing up uh totally unedited and it was
just a fun event because the message
that I was trying to get across there of
like people getting involved DeSantis
can do a certain amount Trump can do a
certain amount politicians generally
speaking can do a certain amount but you
getting involved in your local community
and your school board whatever it might
be that actually is how we fix this
thing because the machine is not going
to stop and that really is the theme of
today's show we're going to continue
with a lot of what's going on with uh
with Elon Musk actually my phone is
melting right now because he retweeted
me twice this morning and then you know
the internet is all happening on my
phone at this very moment but the
machine is really crashing down on Elon
whether it's politicians or corporate
media they are trying to demonize the
guy they're trying to scare the hell out
of him that they're going to look into
his personal finances and the finances
of his business and everything else and
and it's so consistent with this idea
that the Democrats the Deep State the
machine whatever you want to call it its
priorities
seemingly are only to destroy America
and freedom rather than doing anything
that would be thought of as uh
pro-american or pro-freedom or pro-u or
me or anyone else so that's what we're
going to be focusing on today uh let's
start with a tweet from Adam Schiff now
you guys know Adam Shifty Schiff uh
congressman from California who was
basically if you were to look at all of
the politicians over the last couple
years probably the single biggest liar
and there's an awful lot of them who lie
about almost everything but he might if
you were given an award you might go
Adam Schiff you're getting the gold star
on this one in terms of lying uh he
pushed russiagate more than anybody else
January 6 all of the nonsense uh anyway
he put up this tweet a day or two ago he
said Elon Musk calls himself a free
speech absolutist to justify turning a
blind eye to hatred and bigotry on
Twitter but when Journal to report
unfavorable news they are banned without
warning the Devotion to free speech is
apparently not that absolute but the
hypocrisy is Elon quickly responded
thankfully you lose your chairmanship
very soon your brain is too small now
what's interesting about this is Elon
has not come for anyone's Free Speech
what Elon has been trying to do on
Twitter is get Twitter to actually apply
its standards and its policies in an
honest and even way so what Schiff is
referring to he's coming after
journalists is that a bunch of
journalists actually doxed Elon they
found out where his plan was going one
of his children were on the plane that
is an obvious violation of the policies
right and and we all know that it should
be you should not be allowed to share
someone's information just think about
it this way if you saw Adam Schiff at an
airport and you saw him going onto a
plane and you were like oh well he's in
Chicago right now and I know he's going
to land at the San Francisco Airport
Adam schiff's getting on American
Airlines flight 2 246 taken off at 1 pm
Landing It Whatever the threat there is
an obvious threat there right some
people don't like Adam Schiff I don't
like Adam Schiff I'm not trying to hurt
the guy but there are bad people out
there so this thing goes both ways you
cannot dox people that's exactly what a
bunch of journalists did and Elon booted
them for it he has subsequently brought
some of them back and he's trying to
clean up the policies in real time as
far as the hate right the hate and I'm
going to show you a video of Schiff on
Tapper in just a second
there was a ton of hate before Elon
these people seemed not to care about it
because the hate was all going towards
us now the hate maybe is going the other
way I don't even have any evidence of
that that there's suddenly more hate
being directed at lefties I just don't
see it as I keep telling you I'm seeing
more and more love there because people
are actually seeing my tweets again so
there's a response a natural response to
what I tweet about in any event they're
very concerned about hate and hate
speech and all of these mean things that
people say of course uh in America
according to the founding documents you
are allowed to say mean things about
people we have some very slim parameters
around that you can't directly threaten
somebody you can't yell fire in a
crowded theater with the intent to do
harm uh but beyond that you know you're
pretty much good so this has nothing to
do with anything that Adam Schiff should
care about uh but I think there might be
something else going on there here's
Schiff and Jake Tapper Democrat activist
Jake Tapper talking about hate and
censorship I think we've got a big
problem right now with social media
companies and their failure to moderate
content and the explosion of hate on
Twitter the Banning of journalists on
Twitter
I don't think these companies should
enjoy an immunity from liability when
they behave this way you know we can't
tell them what to say or not say but we
we gave them immunity we said if you'll
be responsible moderators of content we
will give you immunity they haven't been
so why should they continue to enjoy
that immunity from from responsibility
and liability you got to give Donald uh
Donald Trump a little credit here right
when he called him Shifty shift I mean
there was something so Shifty about that
guy and this idea that he's suddenly
concerned that people are getting
suspended
could you do a little Googling for me on
while we're doing the program today uh
did Adam Schiff say anything when Jordan
Peterson was suspended from the Twitter
uh did Adam Schiff say anything when
Dave Rubin was suspended from the
Twitter did Adam Schiff say anything
when James Lindsay was suspended from
the Twitter when Dr Robert Malone was
suspended from the Twitter uh when Dr J
bhattacharya was suspended from the
Twitter when Dr McCullough was suspended
from the Twitter uh thank you Phoenix
has put on the prompter no I appreciate
that Phoenix uh yeah they did not care
when people who were on the other side
of things were getting suspended now
Elon comes in he tries to clean it up in
a transparent way one of the things
that's interesting
that's happening right now is we are so
used uh used to the to the lack of
transparency we're supposed we're so in
the fog all the time and unable to
communicate with these tech companies
right so all of us are on Gmail let's
say right almost everyone's on Gmail if
you got locked out of your Gmail account
do you know the phone number for Google
nobody does do you know how to get
anyone from Google into a live chat or
anything else nobody does the lack of
transparency transparency is so
ubiquitous it's so like we don't even
think about it anymore it's just baked
in at this point that now when when
someone comes in and says hey I'm going
to try to deal with these policies
honestly I'm going to take polls on
things see what people think I'm going
to change policies on the fly if I get
some pushback people are absolutely
freaking out about it but what this
really all is about obviously is that
there is a certain set of people who
have lied about everything for a long
time Donald Trump is a Russian spy
vaccine mandates lockdowns work masks
work they have gotten absolutely ever
everything wrong and they were protected
by the corporate press and by big Tech
now that some of that is coming out and
people are waking up to the lies they're
freaking out that's why they're
threatening Elon they can't have the
truth get out there because if you're
one of the people who in this case uh
now that we know that the FBI was
literally working with Twitter to
silence people and paying people will do
more on this story tomorrow the FBI was
actually paying Twitter to silence
people yes it is true there's evidence
of it now through these leaked emails if
you were one of the bad guys in that
situation you don't want that [ __ ]
getting out there right you don't want
that to be exposed so you have to censor
people but we as I always say have to
not forget who the Liars are and with
that in mind here's a video compilation
of Adam Schiff lying the center of many
of these investigations is going to be
the house intelligence committee and at
the head of that committee is its
chairman Adam Schiff but we do know this
the Russians offered help the campaign
accepted it help the Russians gave help
and the president made full use of that
help and that is pretty damning the U.S
response to the Russian hacking of our
election has been influenced by
something whether it's simply Donald
Trump reacting to the question that's
been raised about his legitimacy because
of the the taint over the election but
when people say there's no collusion
they must have a different word for the
kind of corrupt coordination of effort
between the Trump campaign and the
Russians we know that the president has
made
probably over a thousand false
statements about the Russia issues clear
that the Trump campaign welcomed Russian
help built it into their campaign plan
never reported it and made full use of
it and then lied about it that there's a
real risk in not moving forward with an
impeachment so the president once again
sought for an interference in an
election Bob Mueller did not find that
there was no collusion in fact in the
first couple pages of report he said we
don't address that issue what we found
is we could not prove criminal
conspiracy Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
every single thing that that man has
said for the last five years in the
public sphere has been a lie he has cost
America millions and millions of dollars
and and thousands and thousands of hours
of wasted Manpower through two
impeachments and the January sixth
hearing and everything else Russia
collusion was all nonsense if you want
to look for Russian collusion you'd have
far more evidence that Hillary was up to
something and by the way Barack Obama
then Donald Trump but they lie about
everything and now that it's coming out
he must threaten Elon Musk that's why
he's posting that tweet earlier he wants
Elon to start sweating he wants Elon to
go you know just have it in the back of
his head all the time boy I really am
pissing off powerful people and they've
got the CIA and FBI and they could look
into my companies and they could audit
us and God knows what else they could do
to us maybe I should ease up but Elon
Musk hasn't shown no signs of easing up
and this game is afoot and we shall see
what happened but as we shall see what
happens but as all this is happening uh
CNN the one-time News Network known as
CNN uh they're starting to freak out
because uh people are finding out the
truth so CNN is talking about possibly
leaving Twitter
I think this raises a big question about
what the Free Press what the future of
the Free Press on Twitter looks like you
know our news organizations going to
stand by as the reporters are just you
know hastily banned without explanation
uh CNN is saying it's going to
reevaluate its relationship with Twitter
based on the response it gets I want to
read you the full statement Allison it
says
um
the impulsive and unjustified suspension
of a number of reporters including CNN's
donio Sullivan is concerning but not
surprising and it goes on to say
Twitter's increasing instability and
volatility volatility
should have should be of incredible
concern for any everyone who uses
Twitter and then it goes on to say we've
asked Twitter for an explanation and we
will reevaluate our relationship based
on that response and I think it's so
important to point out that Twitter
really needs or really relies on news I
mean that's what's the kind of the
lifeblood
no lady Twitter does not rely on
journalists you guys have been the prime
purveyors of all the lies and what
you're upset about now is that other
people have blue checks and everyone's
got one of these and that means that
they can be journalists because they can
expose you guys when you selectively
edit the news you guys have lied CNN has
lied about everything I do this all the
time we can go through it very fine
people on both sides Brett Kavanaugh has
a serial rapist Jesse Smollett got hung
with the after eating at Subway all of
the lies right so they've lied coveted
all the coveted stuff it's all you guys
get all of it CNN has done all of that
so if CNN was to leave Twitter I think
that would be an incredible win and an
incredible blow against misinformation
right of CNN and that clown out Oliver
Darcy and the rest of those panelists if
they got off Twitter and again they're
referencing what they're referencing is
Elon Banning temporarily a journalist
for having doxxed him that's what
they're referencing he didn't ban
somebody because they said Elon Musk is
a mean dude okay these are the very same
people who of course I don't need
Phoenix to Google it for me this time
did not say a word when Dr Robert Malone
and Jordan Peterson and James Lindsay
and everybody else was suspended so the
shoe is on the other foot and these
people are suddenly realizing what
principles are but dare I say it's a bit
too late however
not as all not all is Rosie at the
moment because it is possible that Elon
will put down the Reigns of Twitter he
put up a Twitter poll uh two nights ago
should I step down as head of Twitter I
will abide by the results of this poll
over 17 million people voted and 57 uh
said yes that he should step down uh 42
percent said no that he should not he
Then followed up
as the saying goes be careful what you
wish as you might get it now what's
interesting about this is look Elon is
obviously not making a decision to stay
or go as as Twitter head uh buy a poll
however
he well let's do it this way first what
I really think he was doing there was
doing a massive bot fishing experiment
right because when the poll first came
out the people that wanted him the nose
the people that wanted him to stay were
way ahead then over time it went the
other way and I think what he's doing
now is just collecting Mass information
like where are these yeses coming from
are they coordinated are they coming in
batches like he's I I really believe
this I think he's auditing the system in
real time is what he's doing now as far
as whether he'll come and go first off
he didn't say when he would come or go
he said I'll abide by it but okay it
doesn't mean he's going to step down
tomorrow and there that doesn't seem
like what he's going to do he may have a
whole bunch of people lined up that he's
ready to hire if he decides to leave and
by the way on top of everything else my
my own
personal view on this would be that the
guy who is sending us to Mars and the
guy who's working on neurolink and
starlink and all of these other things
maybe he should be focusing on those
things right if you're if you're CEO of
SpaceX which he is it's like that's a
job you don't have a lot of other time
to be also running Twitter and running
five other companies so maybe he should
go to that go back to that but I think
what he did here was buy the freaking
thing expose a whole bunch of stuff and
now you need a a strong principled
person to come in and do some of the
dirty work so I don't think he's going
to remain CEO forever I don't think the
poll itself means that much but maybe he
did do this great bot fishing experiment
and we shall see uh anyway all of this
leads to what are the Democrats and the
Machine focusing on in the midst of this
we are we are literally finding out that
our intelligence Services were paying a
social media company to silence you okay
we that is what we now know we know that
they were hiding information related to
Hunter Biden's laptop we now know that
they were hiding information related to
covid this is what our intelligence
Services they were activated
against us the citizens of the United
States on our dime we fund them by the
way so what are the Democrats focused on
are they focused on cleaning that up are
they focused on protecting our right to
free speech and our right to privacy and
all those things or are they focused on
making sure that a certain orange man
can never be president again well I
think you know the answer to that
because the January 6th hearings which
came to a close officially yesterday
announced their recommendations these
recommendations have no legal Authority
nothing is going to come of this it's
much good it's going to be like the
Mar-A-Lago documents and everything else
but the show must go on because when
you're a fraudster you've got to keep
everybody thinking the show is really
what the important thing is here is that
Adam Schiff guy talking about the
January 6th hearings and trying to still
at this point
scare the bejesus out of you but the
second responsibility is to bring about
reforms needed to address the
deficiencies that made us so vulnerable
on the sixth and we will be making
recommendations for those legislative
reforms but the vast majority of them
will not be law by the end of this
session and so you know to contemplate
going into a new session where you know
people who voted to overturn the
election will be essentially running the
House of Representatives uh you can
imagine how difficult it will be to take
these additional steps that we need to
protect the country so I'm deeply
concerned about it you know we I think
in these hearings show just how close we
came to losing our democracy
soulless lizard person it's all I got we
did not come close to losing our
democracy and as a matter of fact and
you can find them on Twitter now because
Donald Trump has been reinstated his
tweets leading up to it all said do not
be violent in essence they said you can
have your voice heard but do not be
violent there was no coordinated coup of
the United States where a bunch of
people as if this was the movie Air
Force One with Harrison Ford uh had a
plan to do something there was no plan a
whole bunch of people showed up they
brought no weapons okay Donald Trump
called Nancy Pelosi that morning
requesting more Capitol Police and Nancy
Pelosi denied the request all right we
did not come close to losing our
democracy even if they had taken over
the building had they taken over the
building I'm talking every uh
Congressional office taken over the
commissary right and it's just free
chicken fingers and fish sandwiches for
everybody okay even if they had done all
that it wouldn't have lasted more than a
day and even if they had done that they
wouldn't have suddenly magically had
power over the military or over any
branch of government or anything this is
complete fear-mongering nonsense but
wait
till you hear this one this one for all
of the jokes I have made about Karin
Jean-Pierre who again she was only hired
because she's a black lesbian she is
deeply unqualified I don't know that
there is anyone actually I would love to
get an answer on this please in the
comments section we'll check some on
locals I'll read some at the end of the
show today is there anyone in the
history of the world who has been worse
at their job than Korean Jean-Pierre
like absolutely worse every single
statement she makes as a representative
of this Administration is a lie or an
obfuscation or a confusion I can't
imagine I cannot imagine someone at any
job ever being worse than what Karen
John Pierre is at her job here she is
yesterday uh saying that January 6 is
the worst attack on Democracy since the
Civil War huh so I'll first saying
you've heard me say this many times and
the president as well we've been very
clear from the beginning that what we
saw on January 6 was the worst attack on
our demand democracy since the Civil War
and the president has been very clear
our democracy continues and remains
under threat and we all have a have a
part to protect it
it's like nothing should surprise us
anymore right you shouldn't be surprised
by that most vile disgusting statement
um does she not remember I know she's
she's young but does she not remember uh
you know not too long ago 21 years ago
with basically 3 000 I think it's 2996
people American citizens were killed on
9 11. I lived in New York City during 9
11 does she not have any recollection of
that the thing is she does
and that's how they want to escalate
January 6th
right they want you to think it was
worse than 9 11. we put this together I
thought this was kind of clever uh for
saying you've heard me say this many
times and the president as well uh we've
been very clear from the beginning that
what we saw on January 6 was the worst
attack on our democracy since the Civil
War and the president has been very
clear our democracy continues and
remains under threat and we all have a
have a part to protect it
horrible people horrible people have no
more jokes to make about her just
absolutely horrible people and and not
deserving of standing at that Podium and
to me and I know it's like it's by
Design so they will never and they can't
fire her right because then if they were
to fire her she would say that the Biden
Administration is anti-black and
anti-lesbian even though we just brought
that lesbian back from Russia but that's
what she would do because diversity
these diversity hires basically put you
in a hostage situation but that is
inexcusable and embarrassing and it's
just so consistent with everything that
these people do but what should they be
focused on what should they be focused
on if they can't focus on the big Tech
censorship and how the intelligence
Services were silencing us and things
like that if that's a little too a
little too scary right it's a little
it's kind of dirty and scary at the very
least and it's confusing you know nobody
wants to go against the FBI okay fine at
the very least could they protect the
Border could they possibly protect the
Border because we do know that this past
year we have basically had more broader
Crossings than at any point go going
forward there was that orange man years
ago who kept saying let's build a wall
and you don't have a country if you
don't have a border everyone called him
racist now we just have people rampaging
over the Border uh Karen Jean-Pierre was
asked about that situation and there's
estimates of 50 000 migrants in Mexico
waiting to cross at title 42 M's is that
accurate and would that overwhelmed
border patrol so look I don't don't have
a a number for you at this time what I
can say is that we know smoggers will
try to spread misinformation to take
advantage of these vulnerable migrants
but I want to be very clear here the
fact is that the removal of title 42
does not mean the border is open anyone
who suggests otherwise is simply doing
the work of these Smugglers who again
are spreading misinformation and which
are which is very dangerous when title
42 goes away as we are uh as we have to
do because of a court order which is on
Wednesday as all of you know we will go
back to title eight which allows a
process to make sure that people can
make their Asylum claims hurt okay
rather extraordinary lady the border is
not open the border is not open and it's
only Smugglers that are getting these
people across these migrants you know
she keeps using the phrase migrants
because migrants somehow implies that
they're just coming here for work and
they're okay people we don't know what
these people are we have no idea what
their beliefs are we also have enough
problems in our country that I'm pretty
sure we could close our border and take
a week to figure out some stuff and then
we could talk about it but what are you
saying lady it's just these Smugglers
that are bringing all these people
across well hot diggity dog here's video
from this weekend
do you need
babies
as you can see there by the last video
we've hired the Predator to guard the
Border that's what we're at we're up
against at this point the Predator using
heat technology is defending the Border
he had to be privately contracted
because the government won't do it but
does any of that look like these are
Smugglers that these people are being
smuggled in there's no way to figure out
what's going on here literally lines up
hundreds of thousands of people just
kind of wandering on through all good
you don't even have to walk like this
you can just kind of wander in it's all
good right there's no problem here
absolutely crazy uh the the portion of
that video where it was a bunch of
people sleeping on the floor that is the
El Paso Airport that was yesterday now
what's fascinating about this is it
seems like there were dozens if not
hundreds of people there remember when
what was it how many people was it 25
people was it 50 people let's say 100
people went to Martha's Vineyard
remember when they bust them up to
Martha's Vineyard Rhonda said just bust
them over Martha's Vineyard the media
went bananas for five days it's going to
overtake the island there are no
Services Martha's Vineyard one of the
richest places in all of the United
States Barack Obama has a 30 acre
mansion on the water there he could have
put a couple tents up but I guess maybe
he was busy or just didn't pick up the
phone
um everybody went crazy for three days
do you think that El Paso has a ton of
resources and a ton of money and they've
but nobody AOC doesn't give a flying F
right no Democrat cares about this this
was not on CNN or New York Times or
Washington Post or anywhere else so do
you get it and again this is why they
have to censor us because enough of us
are seeing the truth that that's not
even partisan nothing I even said there
was partisan it's not partisan to think
we should have a border it's not
partisan to think we should be able to
defend that border as we see fit and
decide who comes into this country and
it's not partisan to think that we
should treat our border towns the same
way that we treat our very very rich
Elite towns
none of that is partisan it's just
reality uh but uh don't worry despite
all everything we just showed you
Corinne's on it and uh well just don't
look behind the curtain but again plain
English to migrants who might be
thinking about it what should they do
after Wednesday I just laid that really
clear it it would be wrong to think that
the border is open it is not open and I
just want to be very very clear about
that lady it's open you're a liar yes we
can get this is what they do they want
you to be lost in the Linguistics of it
what does it mean open open meaning that
we would have no protection there
whatsoever and people could just Rampage
through like this was The Walking Dead
she's just using linguistic nonsense
that's all she's doing the Border in
effect is open this is exactly what the
Democrats want and why do they want it
because they want more Democrat voters
they want more people to come here and
get on the Dole because their policies
will put people on the Dole and they
will in essence live like modern slaves
and by the way you don't have to take my
word for that because that's what's been
happening happening in California in
communist California they bring in all
of these people they basically give them
services and give them phones and give
them money they end up ruining
communities not even by their own fault
because there aren't enough proper jobs
also you should have to come here
legally and everything else and even
this is extraordinary guys because this
is a pretty rare one for me even that
soulless lizard person Gavin Newsom even
he now is realizing the results of their
policies and realizing that when you
bring in thousands of people and you
just give them stuff that hey it's not
fair to the people who are legally here
or who are waiting online to get here
legally but it puts stress on the system
that the system cannot deal with Gavin
Newsom is realizing it I cannot believe
this I should be drinking
right now
in an interview with a national network
ABC News Governor Gavin Newsom said the
federal government should be doing more
to address the migrant crisis he said
the federal government keeps sending
planes and buses to California full of
migrants because of all the good work he
says the state is doing for the
Immigrant Community like providing
health care but he says the state is
simply overwhelmed he said with title 42
being lifted in just one week the state
will not be able to handle the influx he
said nine shelters along the border are
already at capacity the fact is what
we've got right now is not working and
is about to break in a post 42 World
unless we take some responsibility
ownership and I'm saying that as a
Democrat I'm not saying that to point
fingers I'm saying that as a father I'm
saying that as someone that feels
responsible for being part of the
solution and I'm trying to do my best
here okay I want to be clear about my
sympathy for Gavin Newsom I actually
have no sympathy forgot so this is
exactly what he wants he's now using
this to try to hurt Biden right because
he wants to run for president for spot
and forced by now so that's that's all
obvious and I'm saying it as a
father-in-law it's like you're for all
this [ __ ] man you you're for all this uh
why are you giving illegal immigrants
health care if someone is here illegally
by definition they are breaking the law
you got to go you gotta go I don't mean
to be a dick about it but you gotta go
you don't have to go home but you can't
stay here right that's the situation
that we are in with these people but
Gavin has done this to his State and I
would say good luck with all of that in
California because the implosion is on
the way and you guys voted for it and
you re-elected him and everything else
uh but you know at the end of the day
the border is the responsibility of the
federal government so you would think
that Joe Biden would head down there
right I mean you would imagine that Joe
Biden might get on down there he he
takes his bike rides in Delaware every
now and again maybe he could I'm sure
there's a bike path around the Border
somewhere so you think he'd go down
there but uh Corinne doesn't seem to
think he's gonna make his way so does
the president have any plans to go to
the borders now a good time to go like
you said I've addressed this before look
the president's Focus right now is to
come up with Solutions let's focus on
making sure that we have the resources
to manage what the challenges that we're
seeing meaningless dribble we need
resources we're going to manage it why
won't Biden go there because they don't
want to draw any more attention to the
disaster that's there because if Biden
goes to the Border then mainstream media
has to cover it right they would be
forced to cover it because they cover it
every time he eats ice cream and he does
eat a lot of ice cream they cover when
he sniffs hair a little bit less but
they would be forced to cover it that
would be a problem for them so she just
says meaningless dribble and ignores it
but as all of this is happening you know
they're saying
who are they I'm not sure but they're
saying that the Biden's feeling pretty
good about things because the Red Wave
did not materialize although the
Republicans got the house back and I
think it'll basically stall Biden for
two years uh there's a general feeling
that Biden's feeling pretty good about
this thing and these clown people in the
machine these Chuck schumers these Nancy
Pelosi's etc etc uh they're they're
sticking with Joe uh even though he
obviously has dementia and is not well
and everything else CNN did an interview
with uh they say it's their first ever
joint interview uh Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi eating sandwiches and
talking about Joe Biden watch Nancy
eating I don't like any of this you're
stepping aside do you think President
Biden should step aside for a younger
generation I think President Biden has
done an excellent job as president of
the United States I hope that he does
seek re-election he's been a great
president what he's accomplished a lot
of people run again yeah he's done an
excellent excellent job and he runs I'm
going to support him all the way God if
Nancy's Dentures had fallen out during
that like I think I would have ended the
show I would have just we would have
played that clip and I would have been
like goodbye everybody I did everything
I could do here uh first off that's
Martha raddatz I think was the
interviewer there was that was that
Martha Raditz do on that one or yeah I
think so uh she uh she says to Nancy
[ __ ] you're stepping aside no Nancy's
not stepping aside Nancy's being kicked
out they lost the house so Nancy's got
to go stepping aside would be like you
know I'm feeling pretty good about
things here guys and I'm in charge and
everything else but you know I'm getting
old and my husband I think is gay having
sex with weirdos sex drug people who
breaking into our house and my dentures
are falling out my eyebrows are getting
too high I'm stepping aside that's not
what she's doing she's being booted out
anyway it's all by Design because then
when she asked them well are you going
to support them again oh my God no one's
done better than Joe Biden economy
Ukraine other stuff you get it but
they're never gonna stop they're never
gonna stop because they have the entire
machine
on their side so now watch this video
this is this is really incredible like
if you want like the most perfect
example of virtually everything that I
talk about on this show how the
mainstream media laanders the lies and
how they work with the Democrat Party so
that when you see something right in
front of you that you know it's true
that right now who is responsible for
the Border like let's just pause here
for a sec who's responsible for the
Border it's the president of the United
States right that is one of the few
things that the federal government is
supposed to do so we just showed you
those videos all of these people are
coming across I don't think anyone is
doubting the numbers right with these
insane border crossings I think over 2
million this year so that is the fault
of the Democrat party and the president
these are just facts you may not like
them
but they are facts and by the way if it
was a Republican president and this was
happening then it would be the fault of
the Republican president but listen to
the way ABC's Martha raddatz raises this
question related to whose fault it is
that all these people are coming and
then you'll really get insight into how
they trick people from not being able
they basically say look that's right in
front of you no no that's not what you
see it's something else this is it's an
incredible shell game watch this you
talk about the border wall you talk
about open borders I don't think I've
ever heard
President Biden say we have an open
board come on over but people I have
heard said are you
our former president Trump or Ron
DeSantis
that message
reverberates
in Mexico and Beyond so they do get the
message that it is an open order and
Smugglers use all those kinds of
statements it was it was known for the
time that Joe Biden got elected the Joe
Biden supported open borders it is known
by the cartels they have sophisticated
information whether or not the body
Administration is going to enforce the
immigration laws or not is known across
the world but most importantly known
among the cartels and how do you play
into that what can you do better so we
have every level of government doing
everything we can to prevent people from
coming into the country illegally or
repelling them or arresting them and
putting them behind bars do you see what
she just did there do you see what she
just did that was obviously Texas
governor Greg Abbott so she's saying to
Greg Abbott who has all these Texas
border towns right she's saying because
you guys say that Biden has an open
border that's why people are coming not
because Biden's actions have proven it
so she's trying to blame the people who
are calling out the problem for the
problem itself she's saying well Joe
Biden never said it yes of course Joe
Biden never said guys we have an open
border come on down right like this is
Price is Right come on down spin the
wheel get the cash that's in essence
what we're doing but she didn't uh Biden
actually never flat outside it but she
completely flips the reality that's what
I mean about the shell game that it's
not Biden who says open borders it's you
guys who are not in charge of the Border
it's you Greg Abbott it's you Ron to say
this it's you Donald Trump and that's
what the migrants the migrants the
illegal aliens that's what they hear and
that's why they're coming it's such an
extraordinary subtle uh pernicious
Distortion of the truth uh gross
disgusting but this is what they do to
all Republicans and you must know this
so this will happen to any Republican
who gains any bit of traction I saw this
image on Twitter this is absolutely
spectacular so look at some of these
headlines over the last couple years
when other people were getting involved
when there were when there was momentum
towards other people uh besides Donald
Trump why Ted Cruz is scarier than
Donald Trump why Ted Cruz not Donald
Trump is the scariest presidential
candidate why I'm more worried about
Marco Rubio than Donald Trump if you
think Donald Trump's scary get a load of
Ted Cruz's foreign policy Marco Rubio
should scare you why his nutty views are
no less dangerous than Donald Trump's uh
why I fear Rubio more than Trump so do
you see this guys and this is what I've
been talking about with Rhonda said this
this thing is a comment and just be
aware of it they are not going to stop
it doesn't matter whether we call them
out for it or not they're going to keep
doing it and they're going to keep
brainwashing
I would say a smaller and smaller set of
people but a set of people who do vote
and that's why we get results that we
regret or well that we regret that we
are not thrilled with let's say
um but they are going to keep doing it
and DeSantis is going to be the main
target on their back and remember he is
going to be Hitler with a calculator
that's what it's going to be he has all
of the Trump policies but he's
functional and competent we can't have
that he'll be double Hitler
so if you disagree with them they will
try to destroy you they have made that
clear over and over again and they have
the intelligence Services now working
with them to do that so over the last
couple years if you were quite literally
the most qualified doctor in the world
to talk about the MRNA vaccines Dr
Robert Malone who has more patents on
mRNA technology than anyone right they
will ban you from Twitter and did the
government have anything to do with that
we will find out and yes they will
weaponize our three-letter departments
against you and Chuck Schumer this is
from about a year ago he wants to make
sure you know that you take on the
intelligence Community they have six
ways from Sunday at getting back at you
so even for a practical supposedly
hard-nosed businessman he's being really
dumb to do this
that is a mafia move
that is disgusting now he may be right
he may be right he probably is right
that the FBI and the CIA can do whatever
the hell they want to you and that's
what Elon Musk is fighting right now
that's what's being exposed and
everything else but the way he said it
hey can we show that again just watch
his eyes when he said it now what he's
also saying there is I don't like Donald
Trump so I'm okay when the CIA and the
FBI do all sorts of they can do anything
they want just watch his eyes when he
says that tell you today you take on the
intelligence Community they have six
ways from Sunday at getting back at you
so even for a practical supposedly
hard-nosed businessman he's being really
dumb to do this
so interesting so Donald Trump
hard-nosed businessman he didn't say
Donald Trump's doing anything wrong he
just said they could get you
and he's probably right they can get you
and perhaps they've been getting a whole
bunch of us for a whole long time and
perhaps a lot of that's being exposed
right now and perhaps there's a moment
because of literally the richest man on
earth
that we might be able to just push back
on it a little bit and not be governed
and controlled by conspiracies but
rather by truth here's a spectacular
video I saw making the rounds uh and the
the voiceover of course is JFK and they
just did a great job here
for we are opposed around the world
by a monolithic and ruthless conspiracy
that relies primarily on covet means
for expanding its sphere of influence
on infiltration instead of invasion
on subversion instead of Elections on
intimidation
instead of free choice on gorillas by
night
instead of armies by day
it is a system which has conscripted
vast human and material resources into
the building of a tightly knit
highly efficient machine
that combines military diplomatic
intelligence economic scientific and
political operations
its preparations are concealed not
published its mistakes are buried not
headlined its dissenters are silenced
not praised no expenditure is questioned
no rumor is printed no secret is
revealed
I don't think I can add much to that is
that the situation we're in right now
and are we learning something about that
and you know as I always say to the
mainstream media it's like you guys
don't have to be great but don't be
horrible and I guess that would be the
theme that I would have to the to the
CIA and the FBI and the Democrats and
the Deep State and everything else it's
like
you don't have to be great but don't
completely trample on everything that we
know to be true and good and then most
of us would probably continue living in
some sort of semi-dream state but what
this all really is about as almost
everything is about in the world is good
ideas versus bad ideas right and what I
tried to do on this show is to
communicate some of the good ideas to
you I expose some of the bad ideas and I
talk about what the better ideas are uh
well over the last couple days there's
been a conference in uh it's in Sarasota
and Tampa in oh it's in Phoenix this
year uh yeah it's usually in Sarasota
um in Phoenix there has been the Turning
Point USA America First conference and
Tucker Carlson spoke yesterday and he
actually addressed just that what do we
do about this battle between good ideas
and bad ideas because they don't just
stay in the idea realm once once a good
idea is out there good things can happen
right Freedom can prosper but once bad
ideas are out there a lot of Destruction
can take place and Tucker addressed that
I think there's a beginning
a simpler way to get a sense and you can
put a finer point on it later but here's
how I assess whether an idea is good or
bad
by its fruits
and what are those
well first of all any idea
that causes a lot of people to suffer
for no reason is demonstrably that
that's obvious
but I would also say that bad ideas
produce chaos
they produce disorder they produce noise
they produce ugliness physical ugliness
aesthetic ugliness bad ideas produce
ugly things
that's why our great basilicas are
beautiful
right that's why the dollar store is
ugly
bad ideas create chaos and Disorder so I
would argue it's a bad idea to have an
open border even if you Joe Biden don't
say it the message that the world gets
from your Administration not from Donald
Trump or not from Abbott and not from
DeSantis If the message is hey come on
over and then people see those videos
and people just wander it and that is a
bad idea that will lead to chaos here
and even Gavin Newsom is admitting it
right even Muriel Bowser the mayor of DC
who wanted all of this is admitting that
her homeless shelters are now overrun
with migrants so it is by Design This is
what they do and our work cut is cut out
for us to push against them and fight
against them and I have to say to really
bring this thing around to the front of
the show and we are going to air as I
said my whole talk we will post that I
think later today from yesterday at the
freedom blueprint conference uh I happen
to live in the state that I think is the
is the uh
it is the Cornerstone
in the video I said Pinnacle but it is
the Cornerstone of Freedom right
and America is still the Cornerstone of
freedom for all of this Badness and it
sounds extremely dark and dire and God
knows what else we'll find out
we still got a chance here we're still
the jealousy of the world here
uh but we better be sure that we're
going to defend it I'm pretty confident
that this state is going to do
everything to defend it I'm confident
that a few of the other states are going
to do it but the rest will go all in on
this and and you can't blame it this is
what we really got to figure this thing
out what do you do about the average
person that cannot see this because they
are by Design not allowed to see it the
average person who doesn't spend time on
Twitter or watching videos online who
does not see because CNN will not show
it what's happening at the border they
do not see the Twitter files because CNN
and all these other things will not
cover it
you don't have to be great you guys just
don't have to be horrible imagine if
they just showed a little bit of it then
people would be a little bit closer to
the truth and we wouldn't all be at each
other's throats we're at each other's
throats because we literally live in
different realities because the system
has been designed for that
but it gives me something to do every
time I wake up in the morning you know
what I mean I don't wake up in the
morning like I don't have anything to do
today I got something to do so that's
nice at least uh anyway some comments
from reubenreport.locals.com I asked
earlier in the show could we find anyone
in the history of the world who has been
worse at their job than Corinne
Jean-Pierre looks like we got some
responses here tawley says her bosses
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
solid solid Tali I will put them on the
same level even you know Joe Biden I
don't blame for being so horrible
because he's mentally compromised and
well actually Kamala is mentally
compromised too but it's not degenitor
if it's just like what she is as a
person there's just not a lot going on
up there you know it's Homer Simpson
like monkey jumping banging on a
tambourine spinning like this so that's
what she's got but all right both
horrible people Elizabeth says the only
person worse would be Jar Jar Binks what
was Jar Jar Binks job remember he got
kicked out of gungan City that's why he
was swimming around and that's why he
smashed into uh Obi-Wan and Qui-Gon but
what was his job do we know what his job
was I feel like he was probably in
sanitation or something but I'll roughly
I'll say that was all right Kelly says
uh Dave now that we are starting to see
how corrupt our government is what can
we Americans do voting these charlatans
out of office is not an option well I
think it's
I think there is only one answer which
is that you must do what is best for you
and your family and then extend it
outward your local community
Rhonda as I said in my speech yesterday
Rhonda Sanders can't fix all the
problems right even in a state like
Florida like he's the chief executive
he's done a freaking bang-up awesome job
here but he can't do everything he needs
the people that are running at the
school boards to be making sure that the
curriculum is right and not teaching
these kids about neo-racism and not
teaching them that boys or girls and
everything else so that those young
people who grow up in Florida will have
the right set of ideas so that they will
then elect other people like it's a
completely symbiotic relationship right
so we need good leaders to kind of you
know go right through right but what
what leaders need so think about they're
the running back right the running back
has to go right through and score the
touchdown that that's sort of what
DeSantis is doing and what a good
politician should do and by the way much
what Trump did for a couple years
despite unprecedented attacks we act as
the linebackers right we act as the
people that are that are doing the best
to make sure that guy can get through
but we we both need each other right the
linebacker needs the the running back
otherwise he's just creating a hole for
nothing and the running back needs the
linebacker to make sure he can get
through so can you work with me on a
sports metaphor there how is that
um that's really what we need and so I
think all you can do yes you can vote
for the right people but
well how about this I'll try one since I
have a lot of family just arriving in
Florida uh in the last couple days and
then extended family and more people
coming over the next week or so and
Christmas week we'll be off and doing a
lot of family time I think the best
thing that you can do probably is if
you've got people in your family let's
say that aren't on board all this stuff
and it's not that they have to agree
with you on everything I am more than
happy as I often say to my mom I am
completely fine if we disagree about
abortion or whatever it might be
marginal tax tax rates or the debt the
death penalty or whatever it is like
that stuff doesn't matter but but it's
gotten extremely difficult to talk to
people who we love who are close to us
about politics because people have
become so outraged and again you can't
always blame them for being outraged
because they have been sold a bill of
goods that is not real right they've
been sold something and then they open
up the box and what they get in there is
just a bunch of parts but they don't
even know what it was supposed to be
because they don't even know what
freedom is they don't know what truth is
they don't know what the founding
documents are they don't even have any
sense of any of this stuff so we have to
do the work I hate that phrase every
time the Democrat we got to do the work
we actually got to do the work right
because when they say do the work they
mean the government's just got to do a
bunch of stuff to tell people how to be
I mean we got to do the work to explain
better ideas that really is it it's what
Tucker said because it once those bad
ideas get out there look what they can
do
I think most of us and I referenced this
in my talk yesterday most if we could
just turn the dial back and be like
let's go back to 95.
1995. I think most of us would do it
most of us would do it right because it
was better probably like I get it like
it's very cool that we have this thing
and I can get sushi in 15 minutes by
pressing a button that's pretty what are
we having for lunch today or we're doing
Greek we're doing I'm having some kind
of Greek rap but we can get that by
clicking a button and that's all good
and I'm not saying everything's horrible
right it really isn't and my life is
pretty good uh but the chaos that we're
in the craziness that we're in the the
obsession with race and gender and all
these things
we had kind of put it all to bed in 95.
so maybe if we just try to get that
Spirit back
we could fix some of this though and
that's all I think about that whereas
what did Forrest Gump say and that's
what I think about that that sounded
like Bill Clinton man Mike they're all
over the place lately rubble.com Reuben
report if you have not subscribed and if
you want to play along uh and comment
during the show and a whole bunch more I
posted a video this morning walking
Clyde in the locals Community asking
people how they stay fit this time of
year because it's tough between the
parties and the food and family and it's
harder to exercise and things get crazy
and then you roll into the new year and
you're like what happened to me uh so we
were talking about that this morning
reubenreport.locals.com oh and then I
have two interviews up right now Senator
James Lankford and Senator Marsha
Blackburn that we put up over the
weekend 20-minute interviews just kind
of getting a snapshot of political
ideology and sort of what's going on in
the country and much more and we leave
you with the elderly man pretending to
be president I will see you tomorrow
can tell her anything she's got a
backbone like a ramrod